hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar developing high quality
therapeutic
antibodies straight from selections in
record time
i'm susie valdez of labrutz and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by cartera to learn
more
visit them at carterahyphenbio.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
may have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues
here as well if you are having trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speakers dr
andrew bradbury
chief scientific officer at specifica
and noah ditto the technical product
manager
at katera andrea noah welcome to both of
you
you may now begin your presentation
hi my name is andrew bradbury and i'm
the chief scientific officer and
co-founder of specifica
today i'd like to tell you about
generating high quality therapeutic
antibodies directly from
selections from the certifica generation
three platform
so this is uh this is work that i've
been wanting to do for
a long time but was unable to do in the
academic space and have been able to do
within the uh company within specifica
and so our library platform is based on
well-behaved clinical antibodies
and they are they are substantially
liability free
i'll explain how we how we do that
we have a very high functional diversity
and finally
we provide our libraries exclusively and
the reason we do this is because there
is a famous case
where human genome sciences and
genentech
both selected antibodies against the
same target
from the same library and ended up with
the same antibody and both
both parties tried to patent that
antibody and
genentech was seven years earlier and so
got the patent
now the result of this design library
design is that we end up with
superior therapeutic antibody leads so
over 80 percent of the tested antibodies
have no biophysical liability
over 60 percent have affinities less
than 10 nanomolar
and about 20 percent of sub nanomolar
and we get between 500 and 5000
different clonatypes per
target so in other words we're getting
very very high diversities good quality
in terms of
developability and high affinities
so how do we make this library so the
way
before we get there a couple of
definitions first definition is
sequence known to create potential
problems and i've given a few examples
there
a sequence liability is theoretical it
may not always be a problem within all
sequence contexts
but it does tend to be a problem when
found within cdrs
and that's because the cdrs are solvent
exposed and so
these sequences are are available for
modification
now biophysical liability on the other
hand is a liability that can be
physically measured
for example polyreactivity aggregation
and so on and these are liabilities you
can measure in vitro
and they often are a proxy for in vivo
problems so an antibody that has
aggregation
may then have a reduced half-life may
cause you mean
any immune response you may get
anti-drug antibodies and so on
so what we did was we started off with
the best therapeutic scaffolds
and our reasoning is to start with
antibodies that have actually been in
patients
uh have been injected into people and
behave well within that context
rather than starting with antibodies
that are either very
common or commonly used or antibodies
that are germlines
and so we isolate natural cdrs by
next-gen sequencing or pcr we then
eliminate those cdrs that contain
sequence liabilities
and embed those within the scaffolds
so what this results in is a number of
different scaffolds
each one of which is a sub library
containing many many different cdrs each
of which is natural
and has been purged of all liabilities
so note
that here we have no diversity all the
diversity within the cdrs is coming from
natural cdrs there is no
synthetic diversity within a cdr the
diversity is coming from
the combination or the combinatorials of
putting different cdls together in large
numbers so how did we choose the
scaffold
well we relied on this paper by janet al
which went through all the therapeutic
antibodies
of various stages and in the rows you
have different antibodies in the columns
you have different biophysical assays
and if you assess these based on their
properties
then red flags so in other words
biophysical measurements on individual
antibodies indicated in red
represent biophysical liabilities that
are defined as the 10 worst values
among the approved drugs for each assay
and so if you look at this
this table what you'll see is a
population of about 40 antibodies at top
that have no biophysical assays and then
the number of biophysical
red flags sorry goes increases as you go
down the table
so what we did was we chose five
antibodies at the top
representing genetic diversity that had
no
red flags and one antibody at the bottom
surukumab which was chosen to be a
a bad antibody specifically for the
assays that we were going to do
which are the library scaffolds so i've
indicated them here and you can see that
we have
vh diversity uh vh germline diversity
one two three and four and then we have
vl diversity as well the kappa one two
three and four
and we also have v lambda you note that
in the last column we have the levels of
immunogenicity and on the whole
all these antibodies are have relatively
low
low immunogenicity
the best strategy again quickly we take
cdrs
all coming from real antibodies we
eliminate we
which are synthesized for all but hcdr3
they're extracted from our proprietary
data sets
we eliminate errors and sequence-based
liabilities
and then synthesize the dna in arrays
for hcdr3
we use natural hcdl3s directly amplified
from about a billion b
cells and from at least 10 donors and
these will
because we're not doing any
pre-screening contain some liabilities
so if you look at the liabilities we're
eliminating and this is vh
and we have a list here and you can see
that in cdl-1
eliminating all those liabilities
reduces the number of cdls available by
about 60 percent
and it's about 70 in cdr2
so now one of the nice things about uh
using
natural replicated diversity is that it
flattens abundance differences
so if you do next gen sequencing on
natural source
then you can see that the abundance
range goes from
is is 300 000 to 1 going from the
commonest
cdr which is the germ line down to the
least common which is usually a multiple
mutated cdl compare this to the natural
replicated cdr abundance range which is
about 60 to 1
about 10 fold of which is due to that
steep
uh drop-off which is due to various
errors in sequencing pcr
or or in oligosynthesis
so the distribution of the
oligonucleotide
based diversity is about 5 000 times
better than
natural and we use this for all cdls but
cdr3 of the heavy chain
and other cdls from other libraries show
similar sorts of distributions
here are some examples of cdrs with
sequence liabilities that would have
been eliminated and you can see
deamidation isomerization reconciliation
unpaired cysteines and so on
here we have the progression and
improvement in our in our acdr3
diversity
and so in yellow at the bottom you see
what we call our gen 1 library this is a
library that we
produced or i produced in my academic
life about 20 years ago
i thought it had a diversity of about
just under 10 to the 8.
it turned out the true hcdl3 diversity
was in fact
3 million so about 30 fold less than
expected
then in green is a
library we made from a single donor
we've just published that in
communications biology
and you can see that from a single donor
we're increasing the diversity and that
actually continues significantly
above that in gray we have a gen 2
library so gen 2 is where we take the
vhs and the
4 vhs and the 4 vls and we can combine
them together this was a library made
from 15 donors
you can see that we have a diversity in
the hcdl3
of just about 0.6 times 10 to the 8.
and then finally at the top you have the
two gen 3 libraries that were showing on
this on this figure
which have a diversity of about 200
million in the hcdr3
we've now made altogether almost 70
libraries
and so we do quality control on them
we're getting very good at making these
libraries we understand
what what where the problems are where
the bottlenecks are and have improved
our platform so we can now make a
library in about a couple of months or
so
testing it and quality controlling it
takes a bit longer
so no clonal dominance in the individual
libraries as shown in this table here
you can see that the com most abundant
hcdl3 in any single library is just over
0.6 percent and in the combined library
is about a quarter of a percent
and the most abundant vh when you take
all the cdrs into account
is no more than point zero five percent
and this goes down
tenfold when you look at the libraries
all together
so great design but how does it work
obviously
and are we getting good affinities and
good diversities and so the specific
gen 3 platform starts with phase display
we do a couple of rounds on phage
we then transfer over to yeast
in a single step conversion and this
allows us to fine tune affinities
specificity expression levels and so on
and then what we do is we pick random
clones and sequence them
and we also do next-gen sequencing and
applying machine learning to identify
different clusters and this allows us to
inform in both directions so
by virtue of the cluster identification
following
next-gen sequencing we can see which
random clones that have been picked fall
into different clusters and
examine them further and we can also
identify those clones that are being
more common
both in in random clone picking and next
gen sequencing
this shows a selection sort profile for
selection against gmcsf
um each uh each dot represents a yeast
displaying between thirty and
a hundred thousand of the same antibody
has some copies of the same antibody
on the x x-axis we have the single chain
display level on the y-axis the amount
of antigen bound
and so what we're interested in is dots
found in that upper right quadrant
and you can see that when we go down to
a concentration of target of about one
nanomolar
we still see over 40 percent of of yeast
are binding the target indicating they
have pretty good
affinities when we sequence these using
pack bio and the reason we use pack
buyer it allows us to couple the hvl
genes and we identify different clusters
which are indicated in the columns
of heavy chains sorry in the columns
like chains in the rows
and what you can see is that when we
read about twenty thousand
reads from different concentrations the
number of clusters we identify as
between
eight hundred and about three and a half
thousand now you may ask
how different are these clusters one
from another
and that's illustrated here looking at
the levenshtein distance
when we compare all cdrs one to another
you can see
also hcdl3 sorry one to another you can
see that the
the peak difference is about 10 to 11
amino acids
so when we say that two clusters are
different they're actually very
different indeed in the
in the average difference since about 10
to 11 amino acids
if for now instead of looking just at
the hcdl3 you look at the
full complement of cdl so that's all six
cdrs concatenated together
now you see that the average distance is
between 20 and 40 amino acids
so when we say that we have two clusters
these clusters are not the same
they're not differing by just one or two
amino acids these are
very different antibodies
we found that different targets
preferred different sub libraries as
illustrated here
so gmcsf prefers the vh1 v lambda
library
interferon prefers the vh1 v kappa 1
library and il-6 prefers the vh3
vcapper2 library however
although antibodies although targets may
prefer
particular sub-libraries here's an
illustration where we did a selection
against the mixed libraries
you can see we're getting very good
population directly after phage
and that is dominated by sub libraries c
and d
as you can see both of these after phase
were getting good populations
however if we do individual selections
against
from the other three libraries a b and e
you see that we start off with
less abundant populations after phage
but
by the end of the two rounds of
sorting up to nanomolar you can see that
we're getting very good populations here
in the upper right quadrant for all of
them
so essentially we found that usually we
can select antibodies from all sub
libraries
but there are some sub libraries that
are preferred by different antigens
we find that most sequence liabilities
are eliminated from antibodies coming
from the gen 3 platform
and here's a comparison between an
antibodies that were selected against
the target using the gen 1 library
where you can see that only less than 10
of antibodies have no liabilities
whatsoever
and about three quarters have between
two and four liabilities
when we look at the generation three on
the other hand we find that three
quarters of the antibodies coming out
in this particular case have no
liabilities
these are biophysical these are sorry
these are sequence liabilities
and about 20 20 most of the rest are
found in the hcdl 30 only
and 80 of those are single liabilities
when we do high throughput spr using the
cartera lsa
you can see that we get very high
affinity antibodies as indicated by
these
spr plots and when we plot them out on
an iso affinity plot
um you can see that directly from
selection we're getting about
forty percent of antibodies between one
and ten nanomolar
and twenty percent which are sub
nanomolar and what we've done here is
we've uh selected against a bunch of
different targets
now it was very difficult being in the
antibody business
not to uh not to be responsive to the
pandemic
and select antibodies against farsker v2
and we of course weren't the only ones
to
have this idea and in fact uh i would
argue that what we've
what we've had with the pandemic is a
global experiment that has been focused
on a single target
it's like a big competition the likes of
which we've never seen before
and everybody who has anything to do
with antibodies has selected
or generated antibodies against the
spike protein
and this allows us to compare different
platforms for their
uh antibody properties
so what we did was we selected
antibodies against different forms of
the s protein
using either the generation three
platform as indicated in the top row
or two libraries made from
or two libraries made from
convales a convalescent donor with very
very high titers either using the kappa
chain or the lambda
and what you can see is that the
number of number of yeast after going
through the selection
from the gen 3 library that are binding
at one nanomole
is a little bit less but very similar to
what you're seeing with the immune kappa
library
and much better than what you're seeing
with the immune lambda library
we uh the the
protocol we were following was to take
the phage library to do two rounds of
phage selection
three facts guided sorts take that
output
convert it directly into iggs sequence
96 clones we identified 23 different
sequences
and then went to antibody lab validation
as you can see on the right in the elisa
above and
in the flow plot below most of the
antibodies that we
generated against s1 recognize the rbd
as indicated um in in these
in these assays
when we did a kinetic study
on these antibodies using the
using the lsa what we have here is
the selected antibodies 23 of them
with affinities determined against the
rbd
in a blue circle and against the timer
in the blue triangle
and these are to be compared with
antibodies
selected from the scripts by from the
burton lab
and again yellow circles against rbd
yellow triangles against trimer and
there's one antibody which is able to
cross neutralize both
size code v1 and cov2 which is in red
what you can see
is that the affinities of the antibodies
that we've tested here
are pretty similar to those coming out
from the
convalescent patients used by the burton
lab
scripts and in some cases perhaps even
better
now when you compare the affinities
against the rbd and the abilities
generated against the trimer there's
usually an increase
as you'd expect and you can see that in
the
raw numbers on the left and then in the
change in the primary ability versus the
rbd affinity on the right
and basically the average increase
in affinity is about six fold however
there are a couple of antibodies here
that in fact decrease their binding
affinities
upon when tested against the trimer
we used we also used the lsa to do some
antibody binning
and uh the most common bin uh was the
same as the most common bin
identified by dennis burton bin we call
3b
this recognizes the rbd and is the most
potent neutralizing bin
in addition we have a bin called 4b
which splits
and otherwise have been that dennis had
identified
into two by distinguishing between the
bindings of two antibodies
and then there was
one of dennis's antibodies and bin 1b
which is that antibody i mentioned
before
which is cross neutralizing sales code
v1 and source kobe 2.
when we tested all these 23 antibodies
for neutralization
in a pseudonu pseudoviral neutralization
assay
you can see the curves on the left and
the ic50s on the right
and the best is 1.7 nanograms per ml
and that compares very well with the
two antibodies at the bottom coming from
a convalescent patients
48.6 and 6.4 nanograms per ml
we tested the top 10 for live virus
neutralization
the results are indicated here and the
results are actually
slightly better here so the best again
same antibody was 1.3 nanograms per ml
and uh and now that's quite a few
actually there's there's four antibodies
total
with ic50s less than two nanograms per
ml
now interestingly uh there was poor
correlation between the affinity
of the antibodies recognizing the rbd or
the trimer
with their ic50s uh in live virus as
illustrated here
and this applies both to our antibodies
as well as the antibodies that
were isolated from convalescent patients
we took these 10 antibodies also tested
them against the uk
and the south african variants or those
variants found in those countries
originally
and as you can see uh one two three six
of the antibodies
are basically as potent against these
variants as they are against the
original wild type
and with some of the others showing uh
showing reduced activity against some of
these variants
now as i mentioned earlier this is uh
this is a bit of a global
global experiment going on here these
were some of the
first papers that came out the top
top papers with antibodies on the whole
generated from converse and patients
and if you and these are all portraying
ic50s in various ways
either as curves or as dots and if you
plot
our best antibody against on the same
on the same scale as all these you can
see that on the whole
our best antibody coming from a naive
library here
is tracking with usually with the best
antibody identified in each of these
different uh publications
there are a couple of exceptions so
publication three from zostertal
we're about uh we're about twofold less
and the publication by hanson atar we're
also
about twofold less as well
now if you take each of those
publications
and all the other publications that i've
been able to find have been peer
reviewed
and you identify the top the best
antibody
either for affinity or for ic50 against
pseudovirus or against live virus
i portrayed that here in this particular
slide with a black circle
and you compare all the antibodies
in the published record in the
peer-reviewed published record
against the best 10 antibodies coming
from these 23 that we originally
isolated
what you can see is that the selected
antibodies coming from the specifica
library indicated as selected antibodies
compare very well with the immune
antibodies coming from immune sources
and much better than those coming from
naive libraries
that's true for affinity it's also true
for pseudoviral neutralization
um you can see that all our antibodies
here
on the on the right hand side are better
than the best
other antibodies coming from naive
libraries and are very similar to those
found
from immune sources and that is also
true for live virus neutralization
so what it seems just from taking this
very small
collection of antibodies and testing
them in these various assays is that
we've essentially been able to replicate
the results
of general antibody generation from
immune sources from a naive library
now as i mentioned we sequenced 96
clones we identified 23
sequences we fell into 12 clusters and
tested them
those are the results i've just shown
you but we wanted to go beyond that
and so what we did was next gen
sequencing analysis of three yeast
binding populations
as illustrated here and after we did
our machine learning we ended up with a
total of just over 600 different
clusters
and these overlapped to various extents
depending upon the upon the sequencing
and the overlaps are all defined at the
next gen sequencing level
now some of these are are have been
generated specifically for specific
targets which is why
some of the overlaps are not as large as
you might expect
so we took 178 of these additional
clones
representing 70 additional clusters
synthesize these express them
and further analyze them and so this
resulted in
total when we tested these antibodies
this resulted in additional 82
sorry additional 70 additional clusters
so now when we tested the affinities
again using the cartridge
cartera lsa and compared those to the
antibodies that we had previously
identified
which are indicated in pink salmony sort
of circles
these new ngs clones are in the blue
circles
the previously identified antibodies
coming from convalescent patients are in
red triangles what you can see
interestingly is that there is a
whole population that's jammed up
against the far left
which well essentially what we're seeing
is uh flatlined
off rates and these are really beyond
the capture kinetics of
the cartera lsa and indeed any any spr
platform
and these are illustrated here you can
see these flat lines
indicated in the arrowed affinities
and infinities here rather than giving
specific values are all being
indicated as less than a certain of a
certain amount
so now when we take all these antibodies
and we
compare them to the published record for
affinity then
one thing that's clear is that we have
this off freight
uh car uh traffic jam here
of antibodies that are beyond capture
kinetics capabilities and so we're
going to take these antibodies and we're
going to test them now
for their affinities using the connector
which is
the only platform that really is able to
get down to the
low very low picomolar and centimolar
levels
it is also however true that um that's a
misprint it should say uh 31 antibodies
with
we have 31 antibodies with affinities
less than 100 picomolar
in fact it's 94 antibodies with
affinities less than one nanomolar
and again these are all coming from a
naive library which
which which represents remarkable
results without any immunization
last thing i'd like to talk about is
developability
as you re as you remember we generated
the cdrs
and purged them of all liabilities all
sequence-based liabilities so the
question is what happens
when you make real antibodies do these
do these have
no biophysical liabilities so what we
did was we took single chains
we converted them into iggs
we then tested them for these different
assays
these different properties using these
different assays and the antibodies we
tested
were cerukumab which is you remember is
that known for developability antibody
the parental scaffold which provided us
with a baseline
and four clones from each library
so here's an example of size exclusion
chromatography
of a single clone coming from library a
you see here aberrant peaks for
surukumab which is probably interacting
with a column matrix in a strange way
you also see a broader distribution
representing an aggregate shoulder for
surukumab
we also see additional aggregation which
is particularly pronounced for surukumab
over at uh lower retention times
and then finally you see this single
peak with four
overlapping overlapping plots where the
parental
and the clone which have been untreated
are in the lighter colors and the
parental and the clone
which have been frozen and thought 10
times are in
dark blue for the parental and orange
for the clone and you can see that these
figures these plots essentially overlap
indicating
that the antibodies are are
essentially as good as the parentals
from which they were derived
here's four more plots from the same
series
and again you see that the plots are
essentially overlapping
indicating again that the clones derive
from a particular parental antibody
are behaving almost as well as the or as
well as uh
and you'll see in a second sometimes
better than the parental from which they
were derived
so we we did a number of other
measurements including ac
signs sgac science polyspecificity
hectic
so what we have in this plot is for each
each set is the parental is indicated in
red
the clones are indicated in black if a
clone
is within the therapeutic limits then
it's black if it's better than the
therapeutic limit
it's in it's blue and it's beyond the
blue line whichever direction that is
and if it's in the other direction so
it's worse than therapeutic limit
then it's in orange and so what you can
see
and this is this represents two standard
deviations from the parental mean
and what you can see first which is
quite striking
is that all the clones that we've
derived from these
different parental scaffolds essentially
cluster with the parentals themselves
however there are a few examples where
the
clones coming out are better for example
in the ac signs there are four
antibodies there
that are are clearly better than the
parental from which they were derived
a couple of antibodies a few antibodies
with better hectics but there are also
a couple of antibodies which have worse
uh tms as indicated in the tm plot
so now when you look at this in the in
the aggregate
and say so how many
antibodies have biophysical liabilities
as measured
as described previously then what we
have is over 80 percent of tested
antibodies have no biophysical
liabilities
that's 16 out of 19 and only three
antibodies have a single biophysical
liability
and we have not identified an antibody
with more than
one biophysical liability yet
and so conclusions um is that the
generation three antibody library
platform performs uh
that generates a very high proportion of
drug like antibodies
uh 84 percent of tested antibodies have
no
measured biophysical liabilities the
rest of only one
we have very high affinity antibodies
generated routinely
and we were particularly struck by the
highest energies of the antibodies we
were able to pull out from
the against sorry against the spike
protein we have very high antibody
diversity
usually between 500 and 5000 clusters or
clonotypes depending on the target and
the salt concentration
um and as i mentioned the fast cov2
spike protein selections
yield antibodies that are better than
most immune antibodies
generated from convalescent patients and
within twofold of the very best
antibodies that have been described to
date
we've also found that uh if you do next
gen sequencing
and uh cluster then you can increase
your cluster diversity by up to 50 fold
and the the the amount that you increase
depends on how many
uh sanger clones you you sequence at the
beginning
and so just to turn quickly to the
people that did the work
and so the libraries were constructed by
andrei texera in collaboration with
frank erasmus who did a lot of
bioinformatic work to define the cdrs
and how we were building them sarah
d'angelo built the
generation 2 libraries and as the cto of
specifica
and uh keeps the whole lab running
unfortunately and camilla
are doing the selections this work was
done in collaboration with
rutgers in particular the lab of a
pinter
who did some of the pseudo-violent
neutralization assays
and also with scripps um dennis burton
and dele huang
who did the live virus neutralizations
and with that i'd like to thank you
if you can visit us at specifically.bio
send me an email
a bradbury at specific bio if you have
any further questions
um we supply libraries we do selections
we're
happy to help you with your antibody
discovery
campaigns and so with that i'll stop and
i'll pass over to
noah
and thank you andrea and noah for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on that
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's get started it looks like we
already have some great questions
coming in from our audience
our first question is
how many antibodies libraries have you
made
can you hear me yes uh so as i mentioned
during during my presentation
um we've made we've made up just under
70 different libraries
and the reason we make so many libraries
is is first because we've got
we can do it quite straightforwardly now
but also
we've found that it you you can't really
test a new vector for example
or a new a new selection strategy
unless you actually make a library and
do and go through the whole process we
find that if you
just make an antibody or two and then
and then do
do the work uh it gives you a full sense
of security
or or pessimism so
in order to study the different elements
when we make new things we always we
always make a new library and then test
that
thank you so much now how long does it
take
to make an antibody library
so again um i think i mentioned that
during the talk
and to make a library usually takes
about a couple of months
and when i say to make a library in that
that particular case we will actually
make five sub libraries to to
generate a whole platform and um the the
library
uh after we've made it then takes
another couple of months to do the qc
which involves
next-gen sequencing and also
um selection against the panel of
targets that we know about
and measuring the affinities looking at
the diversity of the outputs and so on
so we're we're confident uh with each
library we know we know what the parents
are
it's interesting we've now discovered
that there are next-gen sequencing
there are diversity measurements that if
we don't hit
we know the library is not going to work
very well
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in our next question
can you customize antibody libraries and
if so
how does one do that so
we can do that actually a number of
different levels and we've done that
uh at a number of different levels so
for example
we've had some partners that have come
to us with particular
scaffolds that they like they say that
they've worked very well in their hands
so can we make a library in their
scaffolds we certainly we can do that
other people say can you
can you eliminate additional liabilities
and we can do that too
uh we've recently had a partner that
came and
wanted a particular liability which in
the literature is indicated as being
extremely rare but this was something
that they were they were worried about
we can also put back some of the
liabilities so we've
we've been very broad in our definition
of a liability
so if you look at the literature there's
lots of liabilities we've identified
some
from in-house work and as as we make new
oligo sets we we eliminate more and more
liabilities
but some people uh don't like don't
a bit scared about eliminating so many
liabilities and so
ask us to put some of them back so we
can we can customize at that level as
well
um and then the format single chain fab
um
the vector we've we can use our vector
we can use somebody else's vector
um we make phase display libraries we
can also make
thank you so much now we have time for a
couple more questions
are the affinities routinely as good as
you
show yeah
actually they they are and that's um
that's a good question we've had
we've had problems with our generation
one library if we got a single-digit
nanomolar affinity
we were overjoyed and so when we saw
these affinities
we were rather surprised we we were
planning to get the cartera
um we we actually got it we tested some
antibodies on it and we were sure that
we were using it
incorrectly because the affinities were
were so high
so we actually sent the antibodies that
we were testing to kartera
and they they tested them for us and and
confirmed
that the confirmed that the the
affinities were what we say so
yeah we as in general um it's sometimes
target specific peptides for example
tend to be
much less uh much less good but on the
whole
it's 20 sub nanomolar and 40 between 1
and 10
on the whole thank you very much
we have time for one
more question do you have any plans to
market your stars kovi to
antibodies well
we're in a glut there's so many other
antibodies out there we'd love to market
them if anybody's listening is
interested then please get in touch
yeah andrew and noah thank you so much
for your time today would you like to
provide any
closing remarks for our audience members
before we go
sure um i i see there's a couple of more
questions i can i can just address those
quickly why do you think there's a poor
correlation between ic50 and affinity
when comparing rbd and trimer i just
don't know i think it's something to do
with orientation with epitopes being
hidden but we're not the only ones to
find that i was speaking to
johanna hanson at regeneron recently and
she said exactly the same thing
it's the difference between biology and
biophysics i think
um does the starting pool of clinical
antibodies change depending on the
target
uh we basically whatever target
we do we get lots and lots of different
uh binders as i've talked about
so and and just in closing um we're very
very collaborative very happy to work
with anybody that's interested in
in in accessing our platform and uh go
to our website you see all the details
there
i'd be happy to talk to you further
thank you so much andrew and noah would
you like to
provide any closing remarks definitely
i'd just
like to reiterate our thanks to andrew
for providing a great talk
and really getting some great insight
into how specifica
does things and really the unique ways
in that they do them
and to thank our audience in general
we're really excited to talk about the
lsa today and how it's
supported specifically in these efforts
and
please anybody has any questions
additional questions that we couldn't
get to today please just reach out
and we'll follow up with those as soon
as we can thank you
and thank you gentlemen both of you
andrew and noah for your time today and
for your important research
i also want to thank lab roots and our
sponsor cartera for underwriting today's
educational webcast
audience before we go i want to thank
you for your interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time
of registration and last of all this
webcast can
be viewed on demand lab routes will
alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time
stay healthy and take care everyone bye
bye for now